là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter à votre classe la rame et non
un peu moins mais si vous ne réussissez
pas c'est qu'il vous manque qu'une seule
chose un tout petit détail le tourmalet
valley comme chaque semaine france info
et l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le
temps à travers les archives de la
télévision pour mieux comprendre
l'actualité contemporaine c'est
l'inattendu et vous êtes les bienvenus à
mes côtés camille d'auxerre et ludivine
lopez journaliste à la rédaction de
l'ina alors ludivine vous avez choisi de
revenir sur l'investiture de joe biden à
46e président des états unis a rendez
vous toujours très symbolique
un rendez vous historique aussi le mot
n'est pas trop fort oui historiques
comme cette archive
c'était le 20 janvier 1961 il y à 60 ans
john fitzgerald kennedy devenait
officiellement le 35e président des
états unis
ce n'est pas le jour j mais le jour qu'à
car comme kennedy coiffé d'un
haut-de-forme comme le veut le protocole
john fitzgerald kennedy 35e président
des états unis a solennellement pris ses
fonctions
[Musique]
le plus jeune président que les états
unis aient jamais élu a prêté le serment
traditionnel sur la bible
[Musique]
bienvenue à kennedy
combien ça a été assez différente
comparée à celle d'aujourd'hui jef k
avait même eu les félicitations et une
poignée de main de son successeur alors
camille pour votre première
participation à l'inattendu bienvenue
d'abord un veau est venu avec une petite
douceur puisque vous allez nous parler
de quelque chose qui semble d'un autre
temps enfin en tout cas de notre vie
d'avant oui de notre vie d'avant je vais
vous parler du cas l'un parce que cette
semaine on célèbre donc la journée
mondiale du câlin le 21 janvier alors qu
vide oblige cette fois ci va falloir
être un petit peu plus distant va pas
faire des câlins avec qui bon vous
semble des câlins virtuels à distance
mais ne vous en privez surtout pas
nathanaël parce que c'est prouvé
scientifiquement c'est bon pour le moral
on libère de l'ocytocine l'hormone anti
stress c'est bon pour le coeur pour le
système immunitaire
alors je vous offre un cadeau pour cette
première et plus précisément je vous
offre le cadeau de l'émission merci
bernard diffusé en 1983 un câlin comme
on n'en fait plus du tout à la
télévision regarder appuyez vous contre
la vitre de votre téléviseur et les si
vous allez ça fait tellement bien non
oui
approchez-vous ça y est vous êtes bien
collé contre la vitre de votre
téléviseur ok on va faire un bon câlins
c'était bon - pour ça c'est pas grave
un petit chiffon humide et fin alors on
se sort mieux non
oui voilà qu alain cathodique ac c'est
mieux que rien pour lé vrai qu'alain on
va attendre encore un petit peu
voilà pour l'actualité de cette semaine
et que s'est il passé le 20 janvier à
travers le temps et bien regardez le
zapping de l'ina ça s'est passé
un mât janvier voici donc le g et f qui
fait son apparition en france après
d'autres pays d'europe
dans un cas positif c'est à dire si la
femme est enceinte il n'y a pratiquement
pas de doute on peut donner un
coefficient de 98 à 99 % de résultats
valables jusqu où des langues le ter ne
sera donc bientôt plus une île un lien
fixe uniquement ferroviaire ce sera
semble-t-il la solution qui sera
annoncée aujourd'hui c'est le projet
franco anglais le moins cher puisqu'il
coûtera une trentaine de milliards de
francs et qu'il est le plus facile à
réaliser
c'est le jour le plus important pour
l'avenir du peuple palestinien dit il et
nous espérons que très vite nous aurons
un état indépendant
sept baleines à bec de 5 mètres
ressemble un peu à un très gros dauphins
elle vit normalement dans les
profondeurs de l'atlantique nord au
large de l'islande du groenland
des centaines de londoniens sont donc
venus observer ce s'est passé est garée
en plein de vie en ce jour nous sommes
rassemblés car nous avons choisi
l'espoir plutôt que la peur la cohésion
vers un même objectif plutôt que le
conflit et la discorde
à partir d'aujourd'hui nous devons nous
relever et nous remettre au travail pour
reconstruire l'amérique
j'avais oublié beaucoup de choses ça
vous fait oublier le souci de pocono
délai la nuit et tonnes de tentes en
décharge
bonsoir
[Musique]
21 janvier 1793 voilà presque deux cent
vingt-huit ans jour pour jour que louis
saez a été décapitée place de la
concorde à paris à une date symbolique
particulièrement pour les nostalgiques
de la monarchie
alors qui sont ces hommes ces femmes qui
regrettent le temps des reines et des
rois
comment vivaient-ils quelles sont leurs
idées leur quotidien un quotidien qui a
souvent piquer la curiosité des
journalistes fait divines au cui
les nostalgiques de la monarchie de la
fleur de liste sont très présents dans
les archives de la télé il faut dire que
la date anniversaire de la mort de louis
saez est souvent un bon prétexte pour
leur donner la parole
premier exemple nous sommes en 1977
moi qui suis un vieux aux royalistes
depuis cinquante ans un ancien camelot
diaw a ça fait plaisir de voir les
jeunes qui continue la tradition partir
du moment où on a conscience de ce
qu'est exactement l'histoire de france
on aime on assiste alors à bala
républicain dans la dans la bouche de
cet homme ça peut faire sourire les
archives nous montre aussi que certains
royalistes sont nettement plus radicaux
oui comme les royalistes d'actions
françaises par exemple un mouvement
ultranationaliste aux idées d'extrême
d'extrême droite dans les années 70
plusieurs reportages leur sont consacrés
comme ici en 1973
une équipe de télévision filmait leur
quotidien entre barbecue bon enfant et
cérémonies confidentielles
longtemps la dérive dans une france
républicaine qui se passe et 2 les
monarchistes de choc ont l'habitude de
se transmettre loin des regards
indiscrets héritage des premiers
immigrés de l'intérieur pendant de nos
traditions et pour les ferries je peux
tu as rendu à l'acteur française je te
fais camelots du roi dans les années 80
d'autres royalistes aux idées politiques
a priori moins extrémistes vont aussi
intéresser les journalistes en 1988 le
magazine reporters allait à la rencontre
des chouans des monarchistes vendéen et
bretons
leur principal objectif à l'époque était
de doter la france d'un roi avant
l'an 2000 loupé on devrait comprendre
que même du point de vue culturel
la france a besoin des rois besoin d'un
roi parce qu'un roi c'est une mystique
un roi cette une c'est quelque chose qui
comporte un peu de merveilleux cette
idée était aussi partagé par un autre
royaliste célèbre vous allez le
découvrir dans l'archipel au qui va
suivre
en 1985 il était président de
l'association des amis de la maison de
france
il défendait avec beaucoup d'aplomb ses
valeurs royalistes n'est ce pas un peu
ringard dans la france d'aujourd'hui
d'être aux royalistes
alors je crois que monarchie démocratie
vont ensemble et en tant que jeune je
suis sensible au problème de la
démocratie de la liberté de la justice
sociale et je crois que c'est une idée
moderne et qui commence à faire son
chemin en france vous avez bien
évidemment reconnu stéphane bern a le
brocciu octobre il avait 22 ans à
l'époque s'est luxé la première
apparition télé de stéphane bern
identifiés dans les archives de l'ina
alors ludivine qui dit royalistes dit
bien évidemment prétendant au trône un
trône très virtuel mais qui donne
parfois lieu à des polémiques bien réel
dans les familles concernées
en septembre 1987 les caméras avaient
fait le déplacement au château
d'ambroise il ne fallait pas louper
l'intronisation de jean d'orléans petit
fils du comte de paris henri d'orléans
une cérémonie sur fond de querelle
familiale
un absent en effet sur la photo de
famille henri le père de gens à qui
aurait dû revenir à couronne en fichant
ray n'ayant pas respecté les règles j'ai
reporté tout mon espérance sur jean le
comte de paris reproche à son fils
d'avoir divorcé et de s'être remariée
contre sa volonté
une guerre des trônes de quoi faire les
choux gras de la presse alors dans les
années 90 ludivine la ferveur royalistes
résiste et persiste presque on a fêté le
bicentenaire de la révolution en 1989 et
les royalistes sont toujours oui alors
les royalistes sont toujours là propres
à ces images nous sommes en 1993
donc c'était effectivement pour célébrer
le bicentenaire de la mort de louis saez
certains royalistes ne s'en est toujours
pas remis notre chère patrie la france
le plus beau au royaume sous le soleil
et la loi salique le spécifie nettement
n'a pas être gouvernés par des assassins
et des voleurs notre jeunesse est perdu
la france est perdu il faut la sauver il
faut vider ce palais bourbon de tous et
là il si c'est leur épure l'année smara
il habite est quand même là oui pas mal
habitées on a certains royalistes qui
vont pourtant au bout de leurs idées
puisqu'il tente mais bien de rétablir la
monarchie et c'est pas banal par les
urnes c'était le cas en 2007 div
marie adeline leader du parti alliance
royale
cette année-là il présentait son
programme aux journalistes dont vous le
voyez à sa candidature n'avait pas
franchement attirer les foules
il proposait un retour à une monarchie
constitutionnelle
finalement il marie adeline n'obtiendra
pas ses 500 signatures pourtant d'après
un sondage bva en 2016 près d'un
français sur trois se disaient prêts à
voter pour un candidat royalistes merci
beaucoup ludivine pour cette plongée
historique plaisir
c'est le livre dont tout le monde parle
en ce moment familial grande et de
camille kouchner l'auteur y accuse son
beau père olivier duhamel d'avoir violé
son frère jumeau lorsqu'il était
adolescent une histoire terrible à
l'origine d'un mouvement et d'un hashtag
qui visiblement donne la force à
certaines victimes de parler et dénoncer
leur agresseur
mitu inceste 80000 témoignages
recueillis en seulement quelques jours
on va en parler avec notre invité
muriel salmona bonjour vous êtes
psychiatre présidente de l'association
mémoire traumatique et victimologie
vous avez aussi publier ce livre le
livre noir des violences sexuelles
comment s'inscrit le livre écrit par
camille kouchner dans la lutte contre
les violences sexuelles en général et
dans la lutte contre l'inceste en
particulier alors c'est je pense qu on
est en train de vivre un moment
historique un véritable tournant
particulièrement pour tout ce qui
concerne les violences sexuelles faites
aux enfants la spécifiquement on parle
surtout des violences sexuelles
incestueuses
mais là on l'a vu ça a généré vraiment
une libération de la parole est donc ce
mouvement me to cette déferlante de deux
témoignages
donc ce qu'on peut dire c'est que l'
ouvrage de camille kouchner et puis la
médiatisation exemplaires de cet ouvrage
avait été surpris par le nombre de
témoignages 80000 en quelques jours
alors à la fois oui et non parce que je
veux dire on connaît l'ampleur
mais ce qui est très surprise qui est
surprenant c'est le fait que toutes ces
personnes aient pu se sentir
suffisamment en sécurité et légitime
pour pouvoir témoigner sur un réseau qui
est quand même pas si facile que ça et
qui peut être quand même violent et donc
de penser l'être vraiment entouré avec
solidarité et sans risque pour de
recevoir vraiment des retours
extrêmement violent alors on va parler
de ce sujet bien sûr la libération de la
parole camille si on regarde en arrière
dans le temps
comment ce sujet a été traité dans les
médias si on se plonge dans les archives
on a du mal à en croire nos oreilles il
ya 50 ans dans les années 70 en pleine
libération sexuelle
on peut voir à la télévision
des intellectuels qui parle mêmes qui
rit de l'inceste dans l'émission post
scriptum un long débat a lieu sur ce
sujet et à la fin michel polac reçoit
louis malle pour son film le souffle au
coeur film dans lequel il est question
dans ces ce justement entre une mère et
son fils de 14 ans écoutez le problème
de l'inceste est abordé dans le film
étant donné qu'il a la chance ce héros
d'avoir une fille mère comme on en rêve
c'est léa massari faut dire que non vie
vraiment une ascèse dans ces cas là
alors comment se pose est comment s'est
posé le problème quand michel type de
travail alors ce débat sur l'inceste en
1971 il a choqué les téléspectateurs il
a même signé la fin de l'émission
mais à cette époque les victimes elle ne
témoigne pas encore à visage découvert
écoutez comment noël mamère on né en
1978 il les présentateurs du journal
d'antenne 2 et il lance justement un
reportage sur ce sujet j'ai très délicat
d'aborder le problème de l'inceste mais
il est de notre devoir de vous en parler
car le phénomène n'est pas isolé en
france il ne s'agit pas de vous montrer
des témoignages ce ne serait pas pudique
mais là encore d'essayer de comprendre
ce ne serait pas pudique de montrer des
témoignages ça dit beaucoup de l'état
d'esprit de la société muriel salmona à
l'époque oui tout à fait en cas il ya
vraiment plus toute cette confusion
terrible entre violence et sexualité
comme si ce serait étalé sa sexualité
ce serait un pudique de parler de
violences de crimes qui sont commis de
graves violations des droits humains et
vraiment c'est aussi ce qui va
bâillonner les victimes sûr qu'elles
n'ont pas le droit c'est honteux de
parler de ça et elle serait coupable de
vraiment c'est que de témoigner parce
qu'elles s'étaleraient l et al rai l et
al rai le rhin leur intimité et des dons
qu'il ya l'intimité par rapport à la
sexualité puis l'intimité par rapport à
la famille aussi il ne faut pas dévoiler
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de la
famille alors justement à quel moment
les victimes commence-t-elle à prendre
la parole publiquement dans les années
80 alors il est coutume de dire qu'eva
thomas elle est souvent présentée comme
ça comme la première personne à la
première femme à avoir brisé le silence
qui entoure l'inceste en france elle est
victime de son père à l'âge de 15 ans et
elle publie un livre sur ce sujet à
cette occasion en 1986 elle est
l'invitée de l'émission les dossiers de
l'écran dans laquelle elle témoigne donc
à visage découvert mais en réalité en
cherchant dans nos archives on a
retrouvé un autre témoignage ça se passe
deux ans avant celui d'eva thomas on est
donc en 1984 c'est une femme qui n'a pas
écrit believe qui n'est pas militante
elle a simplement écrit une lettre à
l'émission pour leur dire qu'elle avait
envie de témoigner elle aussi à visage
découvert et on fasse d'elle vous le
voyez il y a trois femmes qui elles sont
de dos et qui témoigne encore de manière
anonyme
cette femme donc c'est anne-marie
regarder ma mère attendait son sixième
enfant et à ce moment là je suppose que
l'étaient beaucoup malade mon père a
commencé à nous battre les autres
enfants aubin et c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé donc il nous est touché
moi personnellement je mets l'âge 8 en 8
ans dumas et flore et à ce moment là
puis ça a continué il n'a jamais eu de
rapports sexuels avec moi mais tout le
reste presque j'y suis passé donc vous
êtes jusqu'à mes 18 ans dès 8 ans à 18
ans oui ça durait dix ans oui et avec
mes deux autres soeurs également regarde
salmona c'est un tournant de voir ainsi
des victimes parler à visage
découverts qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'elle est pourquoi il ya t'il un
déclic justement auprès d'autres
victimes qu'est ce qui se passe en vain
alors le déclic qui passe par plusieurs
choses c'est le fait donc cette
légitimité à parler puisqu'il ya
d'autres victimes qui parle le fait de
ne pas être seuls de sentir une
solidarité de sentir que aussi le
terrain et c'est que je le redis le
terrain est sécurisée parce qu'il ya eu
une bonne médiatisation il ya eu de
bonnes réactions en fait et que du coup
le discours aussi pédocriminels
décomplexée qu'on a pu voir n'est plus
de mise
il est plus tolérés et que la culture du
déni la culture du viol ce qu'on appelle
culture du viol s'est remise en cause de
la victime
elle ne risque pas de deux d'avoir ce
mur là devant elle qui va les empêcher
de parler cela dit comment vous
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui encore avec le
livre de camille kouchner on le voit
c'est un événement qu'une victime
prennent la parole oui ça montre bien ça
c'est ça qui est terrible ça montre bien
à quel point les victimes ont été
bâillonnés à quel point elles n'ont pas
le droit de parler et que aussitôt
qu'elle parle on va on va vraiment leur
tomber dessus pour dire qu'elle parle
trop tard qu'elle parle pas comme if
c'est la peur de ne pas être crues ou
c'est la honte encore alors il ya
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus la peur
de ne pas être crues et l'appelait la
peur d'être mal traité afin de subir des
violences des violences comme comment on
fait des mises en cause une
culpabilisation je pense que la honte
elle est beaucoup moins présente quand
même parce qu'on en a on a beaucoup
travaillé pour ça mais qu'en revanche le
fait de pas se sentir légitime et
d'avoir peur des réactions est
extrêmement présent et pourtant une
étude montre qu'un français sur dix
auraient été victimes d'inceste dans sa
vie oui ça c'est énorme
ces chiffres là sont énormes les
chiffres sur les violences sexuelles
c'est une fille sur cinq un garçon sur
13 c'est énorme mais il faut voir ce
qu'il a fallu faire et la propagande
qu'il a fallu mettre en place pour faire
taire toute cette masse énorme de
victimes qui du coup sont obligés de se
cacher de survivre seule aux violences
aux conséquences des violences et de
n'avoir accès à aucun droit les droits
de qui sont les leurs de porter aussi
les faits en justice de préparer d'être
protégé secouru soigner alors là on
parle des témoignages et un autre
événement important à camille les
victimes ont commencé à s'organiser avec
des associations et des collectifs
oui ça c'était dans les années 2000 la
prise de parole elle s'est accompagnée
de revendications nous voulons que
l'inceste soirée introduit dans le code
pénal et devienne un crime
imprescriptible
parce qu'aujourd'hui les victimes
peuvent porter plainte jusqu'à 38 ans
seulement et ce n'est pas suffisant
devrait pouvoir porter plainte toute sa
vie pouvoir que la prescription ne soit
plus un passeport pour le viol
perpétuel isabelle aubry m'a expliqué au
téléphone que pourquoi dans les années
2000 parce que internet est arrivé et
que les victimes ont pu s'organiser et
aujourd'hui on le voit avec toutes ces
milliers de témoignages sur twitter
aussi
comment vous expliquez finalement que
les victimes utilise comme ça internet
c'est parce qu'elle n'ose pas prendre la
parole dans l'espace public
alors ce n'est pas fait même pas
qu'elles n'osent pas c'est que vraiment
on leur donne très peu la parole et que
c'est le discours dominant les violences
sexuelles s'exerce toujours dans un
rapport de force dans un rapport de
domination
et puis il ya vraiment on renvoie aux
victimes que quasiment cl compte or en
tant que victimes qu'elles n'ont pas de
légitimité à parler qu'elles sont
qu'elles doivent se cacher en quelque
sorte
et du coup les réseaux sociaux ça a
permis effectivement une véritable
solidarité de plus être seul et puis de
pouvoir vraiment pensé des campagnes
penser des revendications est vraiment
qui est des porte-voix de plus en plus
nombreuse nombreux pour pour portes pour
vraiment parler de la réalité de ces
violences et parler pour les pour toutes
les victimes aussi
alors une des revendications d'isabelle
augmente bien d'entendre c'est l'
imprescriptibilité des faits c'est
important ça oui ça c'est très important
parce que le délai de prescription c'est
une sorte de couperet qui tombe et qui
empêche les victimes de parler d'être
reconnu en justice d'être être réparés
par rapport à cette reconnaissance
et puis surtout de pouvoir espérer aussi
que l'agresseur ne fasse pas d'autres
victimes parce qu'on oublie souvent que
c'est aussi c'est vraiment pour cela que
les victimes prennent le risque aussi
d'aller porter plainte si elle ne veut
pas que qui soirée qui reste tranquille
et qui continue à nuire enfants visitent
les enfants voilà c'est ça ces deux
projets de génération en génération est
souvent celle de carrière entière et que
l'impunité ça permet aux agresseurs ou
pédocriminels d'agir en toute sécurité
donc il ya vraiment ce besoin d'eux
puis de pouvoir de pouvoir dire la
vérité ça que cette vérité ne soit plus
soit panier écrasé qu'elles ne
disparaissent pas que ce soit dit et
reconnu autre question importante la
question des des témoins notamment dans
la sphère dont on parle avec camille
kouchner et qui concerne olivier duhamel
canine oui alors pour le moment on ne
sait pas s'il savait ou non les ce qui
est reproché au politologue justement
mais ces derniers jours on a quand même
vu plusieurs démissions le préfet
guillaume a démissionné de ses fonctions
des établissements où travaillent et
olivier duhamel
elisabeth guigou a renoncé à présider la
commission sur l'inceste la semaine
dernière elle dit qu'elle ignorait les
faits dénoncés on a des images
d'elisabeth guigou en 1997 elle est
alors garde des sceaux elle voulait
renforcer la loi contre les violences
sexuelles à l'égard des mineurs écoutez
la elle parle justement de l'inceste
savez les victimes de violences
sexuelles se sentent coupables souvent
c'est comme les femmes violées se
sentent coupables et les enfants
victimes sexuelles surtout que 80% de
ces violences se font dans les familles
et donc ses enfants sont là et s'ouvre
ya personne pour les écouter pour les
entendre pour comprendre leur détresse
pour le protéger d'ailleurs parce que
quand ça se passe dans les familles il
ya souvent la complicité autour de toute
la famille proche sont les drames
[Musique]
insoutenable salmona cette complicité
autour de la famille proche c'est
important si on ne peut pas arriver à
mettre la pression sur les hauteurs si
on ne peut pas arriver à sensibiliser
les victimes
peut-être que les autres ceux qui sont
là qui savaient sans savoir peuvent
peuvent exprimer
oui et d'ailleurs qui sont obligés
obligés de signaler les faits c'est
quand on a connaissance de faits de
violence devient sexuelles sur commis
sur des mineurs on est on est dans
l'obligation de signaler ces faits parce
que justement les mineurs sont dans
l'incapacité de pouvoir se défendre son
piégé dans la famille
mais c'est vrai que l'agresseur et
recrutent des complices il est il se
positionne comme tout puissant et du
coup dans l'ensemble beaucoup de
personnes vont se mettre de son côté et
vont soutenir en fait l'agresseur contre
les victimes et ça faut que cela change
effectivement muriel salmona je rappelle
que des psychiatres président de
l'association mémoire traumatique et
victimologie vous avez également publié
le livre noir des violences sexuelles
merci à vous pour vos explications et
merci à vous camille pour votre travail
voilà avant de refermer cette inattendue
notre traditionnel pepita nommage bien
sûr à l'acteur réalisateur jean pierre
bacri et à son franc-parler en 1986 dans
l'émission cinémagic diffusée sur fr3 à
l'époque tous les comédiens les artistes
que l'on voit s'engager plus tôt de
causes humanitaires charitables
ou politique j'en suis vous en êtes
certains disent les comédiens n'ont pas
affiché leur mais certains il est certes
un certain qu'on vous avez au courant de
ça avec eux c'est comme ça que ça marche
pas moi je moi moi je dis que si ça aide
je joue le jeu volontiers très
volontiers parce que ça c'est une forme
de putasserie qui me plaît bien mais moi
je veux bien faire la [ __ ] pour la pour
humanitairement je veux bien faire la
[ __ ]
ça ne dérange pas du tout vraiment on
peut me demander tout ce qu'on veut en
tant qu'acteur mais mais tout le reste
quand cette photo interview il faut je
vaux plus horrifique
il faut plus rien me demander que moi
même comme ce que je sais pas faire
autre chose alors je suis pas un très
bon client pour certains pour certains
journaux je passerai mon client l'agent
pierre bacri décédé à 69 ans on se
retrouve mercredi prochain juste après
le journal de france info sur le canal
27 et bien sûr toute la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux de france info et de
linars émission préparée avec les
documentalistes anne delavaux et
florence lui c'est merci à elle
merci à vous d'être avec nous